[Music]
okay
uh as the only woman in this room i'll
try to
speak for yourself i got your back i'm a
woman supporter
you guys ready i'm a woman supporter so
i got your back i am a woman too
i'm a woman supporter
okay anyway so this story here i'm every
woman yeah
yeah he got my back
melody he's a woman so this story here
uh it's very interesting um so this
comes from china
because a chinese publisher
they thought it was a really good idea
to have math
textbooks for junior high students
be different for boys and girls and so
they created
a textbook for boys and a textbook for
girls
and they said that the differences here
is that they were using examples
for boys with like games like video
games or like
cars or boy [ __ ] and then for girls it's
like like grocery shopping and like
more girl appropriate math equations
like how many avocados are in the basket
how do you build a sandwich how many
pieces of lettuce do you use for this
sour
69 cents a pound how many bananas do you
i think the girl one
could stay the same because i feel like
in elementary school it's just
girls are just more in return smarter
guys they need to adjust it to like
what's two titties plus two taking
nope in illinois they got the guy went
because guys are so easily distracted
you need to like
grab the guy study you know girls do
better than guys in a
in a structured learning environment
called like in
they're getting better scores just in
grade school
yeah i believe it so this this article
is about how guys are dumb
no pretty much well it's about how it's
sexist right when i was a guy it's funny
because it's like
it's showing how stupid what they need
to do for guys
but then also how sex that they are
exactly what they think
girls traits are that they need to learn
even the fact that they don't think that
boys can even
[ __ ] use grocery shopping logic
themselves too it's just like sexist all
around well this is actually really deep
because it starts off with a sexist book
right so it's showing that there's
sexist book
but then it's also showing that it's
sexist in china
which means chinese people are stupid
which means that i'm racist for saying
that chinese people are stupid
it's a trap so you're a racist sexist
person
no he's racist because they're sexist
exactly
dang it's a deep deep article i don't
know what they're trying to do with it
it's a chinese finger trap is what
happened they insist trap
in it [ __ ] we got trapped in oh you pull
on one side
this is called a checkmate [ __ ]
[ __ ]
you know you would think you'd be smart
enough when you stick your first fingers
in like ah
oh [ __ ] and you're like this one will
give you i got me
what's gonna make you go hollow it's all
about that's a lot of conversations in
this room
that's true checkmate you're [ __ ]
how do you get out of that when all your
fingers are stuck you're [ __ ]
and you gotta go like this [ __ ]
[ __ ]
your fingers come off with it
but yeah so the the publisher like i
said was saying
that both versions of the text are
similar
in like of difficulty but then there
were people saying like
well what if my daughter is really good
at math
then should she be getting the boy book
like is this how we're distributing like
or differentiating the the difficulty of
these books
and so that's why obviously on social
media it was just
someone's backlash the boy book harder
or was it just different objects because
they think that the
the genders can relate better well they
were saying that they were
they were similar just certain chapters
varied they're not very
clear as to like which one was harder
but
seeing how they're kind of sexist
especially towards women
people are assuming that the boy book
would be harder so
that's pretty much well how many times
do you have to listen to your husband
like that's
that's
you know what yeah why did that make me
so uncomfortable
because it's true oh that's how that's
how somebody should go on there
like uh some sort of robin hood and just
like switch all the book covers
oh that's smart so there's a bunch of
dudes in china right now learning about
groceries and
how many times should you listen to your
husband you're like wait what
i don't think this book is uh right no
and then people were saying like
okay so china's national college
entrance
exams are gonna have a male and female
version too
this makes no [ __ ] sense damn yeah
so is this happening in a big city um
it's a publisher of books oh it's the
publisher yeah they made it they're
trying to like get school districts to
buy it probably
it's so funny because it's probably just
some [ __ ]
you know mine person that's like you
know what we can do
is like we can help kids learn math
faster maybe if we didn't make it so
boring and it like
applied to things that they cared about
they're just trying to make it more yeah
right yeah it came out of good
intentions
for the girls one it's like how many
dolls
does sarah have right even that would
probably piss off americans right yeah
it's more like it's more like it
actually is working
it's like yeah right how many sandwiches
does she need to make for her husband
today
it's kind of like kevin in the office
when it comes to pies he can do
[ __ ] crazy math equations but then
once you ask like apples he's like that
doesn't even make sense i don't even
know how to do that
yeah that makes sense i don't know for
me it's like it's just the skin i mean
if there's actual chapters where the guy
book has
more in-depth detail of like how to
learn something whereas the girl one
doesn't or vice versa
then i think that's a problem but for me
it's like that's just the [ __ ] skin
if you
switch out toothpicks for cash and
you're still counting the same numbers
and you're learning the same
number and same concept yeah then i'm
like who cares well there's a very
different thing that counting toothpicks
and counting cats they
if they if their intention was like well
you know girls aren't good at math
so we have a guy book that's advanced
and we have the girl book for the
stupids
that's [ __ ] sexist and they you a lot
of people
used to think like that and still do
right and then when that when that
example came out i thought that was the
case well honestly not even
so you're saying casey is like well we
can have a girl book and a guidebook if
they're teaching the exact same things
which is using like girl specific girl
specific things or boy specific things
then it should be fine
well no because just the basis of the
fact that they have to separate with
with stereotypical like uh interests of
females and males is already sexist like
that that that doesn't mean
when it's like something that's
universal like math exactly you know
exactly what if what if the girls book
you're like counting like
tampons uh you know dividing like
midwives in a house
uh like you know the content material is
very very specific to their learning at
that age as well you know
every person including people within
each
gender are completely different they
have different interests what if in the
guy's book
you're saying tampons but then what if i
don't use tampons and i just use pads
okay but what if in the guys book it's
like there's five urinals and there's
three guys that come in
where are they gonna stand yep you know
what i mean every other one every other
one
[Laughter]
it's only only a guy somebody was
reading the guidebook another one
because girls would go oh the three best
friends would stand right next to each
other
but for guys hell nah we wouldn't even
stay on board
get out of here oh jesus you do need a
guy in girl pose
like i said i'm the only woman in this
room i'm with you tiff i'm with you this
way
i'm with you i'm married to one of these
people what i mean i'm with you like how
you're back i'm talking about me too
i'm just trying to point out that the
urinal concept you know
true guys guys will definitely separate
logic i don't know why there
comes a age where guys don't want to pee
together anymore like when i was a
when i was in elementary school we
wanted to pee together in one unit when
was your last
sword fight at what age was your last
sort of fight
because you know when you go like let's
say we go out to eat i mean we go out as
a company right we go hang out yeah and
just almost any group i see this we go
out to vegas or something we go eat at a
restaurant
when a girl is like i gotta pee another
girl's like i'll go with you you know
why right
but hold up if you get sexually harassed
if casey got men don't get sexually
harassed casey needs to go pee
as much as women okay
dude you know what's [ __ ] crazy just
recently i saw on instagram this girl
telling her story about how just like
she was coming down from mammoth
which is like here right in la she's
coming down from mammoth and she was she
stopped at some grocery store
oh yeah you like the same post i saw
your name okay so she would stop by at a
gas station and as she was looking at
stuff she noticed that
there was this girl inside the the gas
station that she was pointing her camera
like her front facing camera
as she was facetiming a guy to this girl
that's telling the story
and so the girl ends up saying at one
point like uh do you like her like is
she good
so she was scouting for to kidnap her
because then she
as soon as she realized like what was
happening she just booked it out of the
gas station she ran to the car
and she noticed the guy that the girl
was facetiming was in the car
yeah he was right by the car oh [ __ ] get
the [ __ ] out of like walking towards
their car even though there's like
nothing to walk towards but like he was
like
approaching and then luckily she had her
boyfriend there and they just drove off
but
dude it's [ __ ] scary man that's what
she was like if you have to go to the
bathroom girls [ __ ]
stick together because we get like
picked like it's [ __ ] scary yeah i
heard i heard a lot of things like that
where it's uh
it's the girls that are in on it too
helping the guys that
uh in that story they're saying how like
they drug the girl
in the in the bathroom yeah and then
they'll be like oh it's just my drunk
friend
chill and then they bring them in boom
kidnap
yeah it's pretty dangerous exactly so
that's why women have to go together
they're not doing a very good job
because when i see the two girls go to
the bathroom it's not one girl pink
other girls like this like doing her job
and surveillance they're usually talking
[ __ ] about someone else that was also at
the table
oh you know did you forget that women
can multitask because he's in the
bathroom listening
because he goes to the guy's bathroom he
drills a hole and he's all like
okay oh is that what you think about me
have you guys seen that one uh picture
of the two old ladies
backing each other up like one's at the
atm and the other one's like this
oh that's tight
but how sad is it that we have to live
in a world like this gee
hey when we go out and like you use
restrooms as the husband
should i come with you to the to the
right and stand outside the restroom
door well i mean that'd be kind of nice
if it was like would it be nice no no it
wouldn't
it has it hold on if we are like in a
huge concert or something there's a [ __ ]
ton of people it's really far for me to
get to the bathroom or whatever in that
instance like yeah you should be coming
with me because you don't know what
could happen
but if we're just in a in a quiet
restaurant you could probably see the
bathroom from where
where you are like it's fine it's not a
big deal like you have to assess the
situation this is how women always are
like we're always thinking we're like is
this a dangerous situation do i need to
have my girlfriend come with me to the
bathroom and then that's when
what if casey's what if you guys are
partying at a gay club and casey is the
prey
are you supposed to go with him to the
bathroom oh that doesn't always happen
because i've been to a gay club and i've
been
prayed too by a gay guy oh no but i was
confused by straight men
straight men go to the gay club
sometimes too and pick up women
they didn't card them products away yeah
i got hit on when we went to
for jess's birthday there was this guy
that kept following me i should have
been there
it's okay i i got my job what are you
gonna pray to both you guys have been
[ __ ] oh
damn it it doesn't work like that oh
both of you should have went to like the
gay girls club
oh does that work gay girls no then
she's pray again but it's fine
people can maintain their own i'm just
trying to get you back to
i know and i and i'm always wrong no
you're not you're not wrong
he's just usually in there just
surveillance yeah i know he's like
get the styrofoam cup with the string
tell me when something happens
she's like three cities away you're just
kind of like if you're lying still
waiting
it's like you could use a cell phone you
[Music]
know
[Music]
you